scientists fear that within a few
generations the amazon rainforest may
not exist at all it acts as a vital
carbon store holding the equivalent of
almost 12 years of global emissions at
current rates but alarming studies have
found that some areas of the amazon
basin are now releasing more carbon than
they absorb or it absorbs and as a
result of deforestation of course well
joining me now is scientist and
meteorologist carlos nobre thank you
very much indeed
for joining us carlos and we were
speaking yesterday to a scientist who
said that the tipping point
um that the point when the forest can't
sustain itself was getting very close
indeed what do you think about that how
close do you think a tipping point is
good afternoon uh yes we are very close
to the tipping point we are seeing in
southeastern amazon
uh huge areas of forest
close to 2 million square kilometers of
forest
they are losing more carbon than
removing from the atmosphere during the
wet season
not the the emissions from fire from
deforestation from forest degradation
it's really the mortality of trees is
increasing in these huge areas
so it's becoming a carbon source and
it's showing that all the southern
amazon is very very close to the tipping
point if that is exceeded
we may have we may lose 300 billion tons
of carbon dioxide over 30 to 50 years
making almost impossible to
reach the paris accord targets for 1.5
degrees
and that in itself sums up just how
important this rainforest where i am is
and i mean just give us a sense of the
scale of the importance of
the forest to
global
uh climate protection
uh to use a word that is used often here
they say this forest protects people
from climate change
absolutely absolutely the the the
climate stability in the amazon for
instance the maximum temperature in a
forest area is 30 degrees celsius
and the forest recycles recycles water
very very efficient so increases
rainfall over the amazon basin by 35
due to this very effective water
recycling
you know keeping this climatic stability
and also this recycling of water is very
important to make an export of
water vapor
to the south of the amazon to the and
the indian countries
what we call aerial rivers feeding the
rainfall systems south of the amazon so
this is very important
mechanism which evolved over tens of
millions of years
and we are disturbing this mechanism and
destabilizing this climate instability
which would
reduce rainfall in the amazon increase
the temperature by two to four or five
degrees in central south america and of
course releasing this huge amount of
carbon dioxide
so what would it take in your view to
stop this happening to stop this process
in its tracks does it take a change of
policy from the bolsonaro government or
a change of government
well both in fact i mean
bolsonaro's
position
has been always very similar to former
president trump's position
he threatened even to get brazil out of
the paris
court when he was elected in the
november 2018 fortunately brazil did not
get out but still deforestation
emissions in brazil uh are increasing
since 2019
increase even during the pandemic
so really we need really to change the
the government the federal government
and i i hope that will happen to
elections in 2022
but of course we have all amazonian
countries together we have a clear
clear-cut deforestation 17 of the amazon
forest and we have an additional 17
uh one million square kilometers in
several stages of forest degradation so
so we are putting the amazon at the edge
of a cliff of the of
salvanization so there is no need to
really to keep deforestation going on
because there is
more than one million square kilometers
already divorced with very low
productivity cattle ranches and
agriculture so we need really to to have
a moratorium on deforestation and force
degradation really a zero deforestation
force degradation and wildlife wildfires
and carlos we've only got 30 seconds
left on the program but just give me
how you feel what is your sense about uh
the future of the rainforest
well you know
we have really to to learn more with the
indigenous
peoples who have maintained the forest
for thousands and thousands of years and
who get a good way of life life out of
the forest the greatest potential of the
forest is in its biodiversity in its
ecosystem service